um okay thank you so much for um getting
for giving me the opportunity to um to
talk here today
and um
to participate in this amazing
boot camp and and program that i've
already learned an immense amount from
so
i'll talk about
a bunch of topics that can be unified by
the
general
theme of updating dynamics and networks
although we'll see that there's a lot
more going on
so
a basic motivation which i'll be very
quick about but offer some complimentary
um thoughts to what matt said yesterday
is that
basic motivation in this area is that
people are influenced by others
and learning and information is
a very
important form of that but there are
other pure effects like collaborating
with others or not wanting your opinions
to be too different from those the
opinions around you
um keeping up not wanting to fall behind
appear or setting your aspirations what
you think you can you know what's
reasonable to aspire to based on what
people around you are are trying to do
those are you know there's good
empirical evidence but i think
introspection convinces us that those
things are real and
matt alluded to this yesterday you know
in one of the
big
leaders in this field in economics is uh
sastra
who has many papers but here's an
example where using random assignments
of roommates you're able to actually
assess these kinds of peer effects
in a
school effort kind of setting an
educational effort
there's a paper that became famous
because among other things that made
social science a lot more a lot a lot
more frictional in some ways with
facebook data but this was a paper that
made a big splash by manipulating
people's facebook feeds and
getting very well identified evidence
because of the very large populations
they could work with of emotional
contagion through networks so we have
evidence that that
pure effects in
information and other things are real
and then in other studies we have
effects we have studies of we have
evidence on how important information
can be so
um
rob jensen went and
delivered information about schooling
in a poor central american country
just held a
hour-long seminar with people informing
them of the
wages for middle school and high school
completion and then measured that was a
randomized controlled trial
found that people got a quarter of a
year more of schooling which is an
enormous effect in economics but even
more enormous when you divide by the
cost
of one ngo worker talking to people for
an hour
[Music]
and
so
another study by pascal in dupa found
that with young
african women informing them about which
behaviors were highest risk for hiv
had big impacts with the which they
could measure by looking at the proxy of
teen pregnancy
they could immediately see that though
you know the long-run consequences for
disease are are harder to measure but
teen pregnancy fell by 28 because of an
informational intervention so you put
these two things together
people are influenced by others and
information can have big big you know
movements especially dividing by
physical costs
let me say that
more carefully information has a huge
bang for the buck especially when you
consider how cheap it is physically to
make information flow on people's
behavior and it's not a mystery that
lots of lots of policy makers implement
network-based policies
um
targeting
leaders or
designing their programs in some way
intended to take advantage of these
network effects and leverage you know
the impact of networks to deliver
information and ultimately change
behavior and so
that takes us to a somewhat different
topic from the one matt was thinking
about yesterday yesterday we were
focusing mostly on polarization and
segregation and these things but
when we think of like a whole population
this closely related question if we're
going to you know if we want to know
how networks change behavior you might
be curious about the question of just
like
what would you do to this network if you
wanted what would you do to people's
opinions if you wanted to change their
behavior
and how does the network mediate that so
who are the leaders in a network whose
opinion would you want to focus on
changing if you could
um now there are a lot of modeling
choices to make when you try to make
that into a math problem am i going to
use continuous or discrete actions for
my agents are they going to be very
simple behaving in some kind of are they
like physical particles or are they kind
of sophisticated economic optimizing
agents are my dynamics going to be
deterministic or more realistic and
stochastic
is my network going to be fixed or
changing
in response to maybe random shocks or
maybe even in response to the opinion
dynamics so that those things have come
up the degree model which i'm going to
focus on today for a while is a
workhorse which is one extreme
and important point in the space it's
continuous in actions
very simple in terms of how agents think
deterministic
and
the network is fixed
because of that simplicity it's
mathematically very straightforward
especially for this crowd to analyze but
it's become an important benchmark for
situations where if we started with
other models like the rational models
that economists tend to be fond of
various questions involving networks are
just completely can't even get started
the group model gave us sort of a first
place where we've got traction and then
we
um have gone far from that so it's a
reference point from which to explore
other assumptions and as i'll mention
every single one of these assumptions
that that so you'll be tempted to ask
and you began to ask yesterday how about
this extreme assumption interview model
could you relax it and for every single
one there's great work recent work and
these are research topics in many cases
um relaxing those assumptions but i'm
going to start by by telling you a
little more than matt did about the
basic core benchmark model so let's
start with that
um
so here's the here's our founding father
in 1974 morris degroot published this
paper in jazza
and he was thinking about i don't want
you to read this page this is a more of
a
history item but um
at that time there was a research area
in statistics on opinion pooling this
was actually before if you happen to
know about alman and interactive
epistemology and bayesian updating it
was before people were thinking about
opinion updating that way really he was
just they were thinking about it much
more heuristically and ad hoc
degroot asked what are reasonable
procedures that a team of statisticians
might use to
evolve their beliefs
about
he was actually thinking about a
distribution you can see a distribution
over omega people had distributions over
the weather or what have you and he
wanted to think about pulling them and
he formulated this model that matt has
already introduced
well so um
let me just
for the sake of being self-contained
i'll put the updating rule again
i'm using
a different symbol for matt but
otherwise it's what you saw yesterday
there's a square non-negative matrix
whose rows sum to one
and the
dynamics of the model are about the
behavior of this vector of opinions or
estimates or actions let's say for for
now they'll be real numbers you can
substantially generalize that but
there's just a real valued opinion that
everybody holds at each time
um and the
law of motion of the model is as simple
as could be every period the way you
form your next period opinion is by
taking a weighted average of last period
opinions including maybe your own
so here's a little example
mr one here carries point six about his
own past opinion
point three about
miss two point one about miss three
and so he aggregates them in this way it
couldn't be simple right
and matt already showed this this
picture i'm gonna play through the video
again of this little dark opinion maybe
we call that one opinion kind of
spreading out initially it spreads out
you know very close to where it started
but after a while it makes its way all
around
and yesterday matt was interested in the
gradient which you can to some extent
see in this picture of the colors on the
top being a little darker than lighter
than the colors at the bottom and we'll
get back to that but the question of
what is this color even right like what
shade of black are they going to get
that is itself a question one that we
answered yesterday and we'll dig more
into the answer or we
began to answer yesterday and we'll dig
more into that today
well here's the answer and this is
really this is a result that the group
stated
everyone converges to a consensus
opinion matt told us the conditions
under under which that's true we had to
assume w was strongly connected as a
directed graph and aperiodic
but the consensus that they reach can be
written as a linear combination of
initial opinions
and the weights the weights are what i
want to talk about and this is what we
didn't talk about yesterday
so these weights so the weight on i is
how much i matters in determining the
consensus opinion
um well it's
it turns out that it's eigenvector
centrality in this network given by w
the defining property of eigenvector
centrality
is well first it's a distribution on the
people so it's a vector of non-negative
numbers summing to one
a number for every person
and what defines eigenvector centrality
is that my centrality is a weighted
average of other people's centralities
weighted by what weighted by how much
they pay attention to me in their update
that's the condition that e is a
left-hand eigenvector of the matrix w
it's a linear version of the statement
that your importance is the sum of the
attention paid to you is a different way
to say the waiting the sum of the the
attention the w that people pay to you
waited by the importance of those paying
and it's a notion of centrality that was
studied before this before the group in
fact in sociology
and so and whereas here we're doing e on
the left well so this is sort of going
over the column right
so
that that can be difficult some of the
rows are the rows are
add up to one the columns can add up to
anything
so it's a transposon program
depending on your
religions about random ones
um
and so in bibliometry
kendall and way and then you know more
recently and profitably the
brennan page
studied this
measure as a as a assignment of
importance to nodes in a network
and we'll see tomorrow actually that or
friday that the same measures have been
interesting in macroeconomics
um
where people have studied
models where
it turns out centralities also matter
so the intuition is why is it let's let
me give you a moment so
i'll well
if maybe you read quickly think for a
moment about why it makes sense that
your influence in this model should obey
this fixed point condition
here's the answer
if you are willing to believe me
that
your influence is going to be a number
that is uh that the
ultimately the consensus opinion will be
some kind of linear combination of
initial opinions
then
you know the way that i can have
influence the impact of changing my time
zero opinion has to somehow be mediated
by what happens at time one so if at
time zero you move my opinion how's that
going to affect the consensus well by
changing my friends opinions at time one
and then doing stuff after that
and
the amount that it's going to matter is
how much those friends pay attention to
me right multiplied by how influential
they themselves are in the subsequent
evolution so if you think about that it
implies it gives you
this this equation and um
incidentally you know for i when i teach
basic markov chain stuff this process
which of course you know just both
matt began to say this and i just want
to make it very explicit
in this model x t is equal to w to the
power t x zero so everything is of
course about the behavior of w to the
power t
but it can be a useful um
change of pers if you were trying to
prove for example stuff about this
matrix converging
actually thinking about this process can
be in some ways more intuitive than
thinking about the markov chain directly
as a probabilistic object so you can you
can it's a nice little exercise to write
a proof of the conditions for
convergence of a markov chain from this
perspective rather than the traditional
one but that's all you know what i want
to what i want to think about is that
once you see this once you have a
measure of influence
you might get interested in the
following if you were a marketer you
would think the following
that
we know that
degree
is very unequal in real life social
networks and if you thought that degree
might be
predictive of influence if you thought
that how connected someone was was going
to make them you know more more
connected was going to be more
influential
then
you might get excited because in fact
degree distributions follow a power law
in the tail
or to some extent at least that's one of
the celebrated stylized facts
of of kind of first generation network
science and so
this was a picture from 2011 facebook um
and you see on the log log plot this is
the
um counter cumulative cdf on a log log
plot you see this telltale linear bit
which says that here the distribution of
degrees decays polynomially
and what that means is in such a world
you might have a small fraction of
people having a large
fraction of the insolence
okay
but i jumped kind of to degrees what did
degrees have to do with anything right
here this this eigenvector this e
certainly
isn't degree in general so let me tell
you first about a cool little um
workhorse model for this
if you take an undirected weighted graph
g so g is a symmetric matrix with
non-negative numbers
um that's all i'm going to require
and you define w your updating matrix by
normalizing g so what does this mean how
much attention i pay to you is how
closely we're related in this graph
divided by my total
links in this graph so di is your degree
in this weighted graph
uh then it will turn out that your it's
a little
proposition it's a fact that eigenvector
centrality is proportional to degree so
if i want to know your
influence in the sense we just discussed
it's actually just going to be
the sum of your link weights
and here it doesn't matter whether i
some row or column because g is a
symmetric matrix right so this is a
little exercise that i
it i encourage you to assign if you
teach this at an undergrad level it's
exactly the same
exercises as
understanding the symmetric random walk
on a graph if you have a graph and you
have a markov chain constructed by
taking steps at random on g
then you prove that the stationary
distribution has this some
property it's just your degree in an
unweighted graph it's proportional to
degree this is the same fact right
well now we we can directly so if we if
we thought that the world was like this
which is a simple benchmark then let me
give you a little targeting proposition
a very direct corollary mathematically
but one with some
importance about targeting to shift
behavior
suppose you have a marketing tool like
an ad that you can show people that's
going to change their behavior by delta
on average and you can show it to some
people who should you show it to well
the value of targeting a set of agents
in this world is their total centrality
that's what the the
result one said
and so
with a heavy tail degree distribution
and now we know at least in this type of
setup
influence is degree
with heavy-tailed distributions of
degree a small share of agents can hold
a large share of total influence
so you can you might have you know
my the colors didn't uh didn't render
quite how i was hoping there was a
cutoff here where fewer than ten percent
of the people have in this in an example
more than fifty percent of the total
you know you take the expectation in the
tail here of ei you get
a small tail having a big share of
influence
and so this gives a strong rationale for
targeting influencers targeting the
right few percent of people can be much
better than targeting a much larger
fraction of typical people so is it
worth finding these influentials
in this model it can be under the right
conditions that's like a free
immediate punchline of the good model
any any questions or anything up until
this point
all right so let's push let's push on
and get so this is a summary of this is
sort of the group theory
in terms of the history degroot kind of
effectively knew
almost all of this and but
more in the last 10 or 15 years people
have gotten excited about connecting for
the group this was just a math result
and he he stated it in terms of a
stationary distribution but the fact
that this is connected to centrality
measures and economic uh and things that
sociologists were interested in anyway
um
has sort of you know been a fruitful
connection between um
social sciences and and these kinds of
things i actually want to say one thing
that the sociologists were studying
the
eigenvector centrality equation just for
its own sake they thought it captured
something intuitive about social
prestige that you're important if you're
an important person if important people
pay attention to you and the group kind
of gives us a foundation if you'd like
for that if opinions are updating
according to the group then your
influence happens to be proportional to
this
measure of of centrality that people
thought was kind of interesting or
plausible independently so it's kind of
an interesting intellectual
confluence that these two different
areas came to the same idea by different
routes
but i want to talk about something
practical i want to talk about something
um real world
so around the time that matt and i had
been working on this and matt was very
interested in these network updating
models um he worked he started working
with banerjee chandrasekhar duflo and
jackson on
self edge um
taking these insights to the field
and uh
they
had an interesting data set
there was a
intervention where an ngo had taken
um a microfinance program and brought
information about it to leaders in
villages who we call seeds because
they're the seeds from which information
spreads
and it happened that you know they had a
certain procedure for delivering the
information but the seed sets had
different amounts of total centrality
and how do we know that we know that
because after the ngo
did did its work or uh actually it was
it was after right or during was it
the sen so the census occurred sort of
yeah so there was a network census that
they did where they they measured the
networks in which the
villagers communicated they asked them a
whole bunch of questions about all their
relationships
and
they were able to then see that the
ngo's procedure ended up seeding sets
with very different centrality different
very different levels of centrality in
these different villages
and so this is a plot where on the
x-axis we have the this is a slight
variant of eigenvector centrality but
it's
very closely related the the over the
total centrality of the leaders and the
ultimate take up the ultimate
participation rate in the program
where information about which
information was seated
and so
it turns out that among a bunch of right
hand side variables including you know
is the support is this person a teacher
or a shopkeeper in the village
um their degree other network measures
the
total centrality of the seeds in the
sense was the most predictive of total
of eventual take-up
and
later the same team did a did a random a
randomized trial where where this was
observational data because they didn't
the ngo was doing its own seating for
its own reasons later they did a gold
standard randomized trial with
kind of testing the same principles and
again found
causal evidence that higher seed said
centrality predicts higher eventual take
up
so one thing that i want to note about
the evolution of this research area is
that you know
i've presented in this one way but over
the decade that this research has been
happening it's not like we knew from the
beginning what the right models were
just to model diffusion and in fact the
model written down in the science paper
was mostly an epidemic a more epidemic
style model like the ones you've been
hearing about in the epidemic lectures
so what is this design is
in monotonicity it first seems to sort
of go down and settle oh you see you're
saying that here yeah so you know i
wouldn't um
i think that the economists incidentally
were not keen on mining this data too
much because it was an observational
study so at some level you could think
that
it doesn't you know the cd wasn't done
based on centrality so so i think they
wanted to keep the data analysis minimal
so that they wouldn't be you know
overfitting observational study but i
think we now do have evidence that this
is so
what i want to point out is that and
i'll say more about this later the viral
epidemic models actually wouldn't give
you in nearly as natural a way a
rationale for in this high set these
high centrality sets being better as
seed sets it was it's really the linear
after after you know 10 years of
thinking about it i think the literature
is converging to thinking that models
like the one i'm presenting today with
continuous actions and these kind of
eigenvector
characterizations are more um
seem to fit better at least the
aggregate data
for explaining these kind of facts yeah
that's a great question i mean as a
general matter you want to
so
um
hopefully you choose something that
tracks the process you think is
diffusing the information um and then
there's a separate question that
different kinds of theories
make different predictions so you could
throw in you know multiple kinds of in
the science paper in fact they did have
multiple right hand sides that they
tried and they found that the diffusion
centrality was the centrality measures
they focus on which is i think almost
exclusively diffusion demand right
eigenvector
yeah so in some sense as a sort of like
you know empirical social scientist you
think
this one seems to be fitting so that
suggests that these processes might be
the relevant ones um and and i think you
know as a
little
methodological perspective on networks
here i think the value of having so many
excellent theories developing is that we
develop a heuristic understanding what
matters for vital processes what matters
for the root processes we'll see what
matters for network games you put them
together it gives you a toolbox that
when you look at a real life process
based on what you see mattering or
happening you can say okay this is going
to be the kind of model i'm going to
bring to it because it fits the thing
you know it has these
stylized facts that look like model x
right i think it's taken even though it
feels very simple in hindsight
it
it wasn't obvious at all that these
kinds of diffusion so for now just do me
a favor and think of diffusion
centrality is very closely related to
eigenvector and i'll tell you more about
it soon
um so
i want to talk quickly about something
maybe a little a little um different
which is that so so far we've been
focused on the marketer who's like wants
opinions to move in a certain direction
and is interested like who can i
influence to do this here's a different
question very different it's about
aggregation
so
um
this is from a paper matt and i wrote
called naive the first paper we wrote
about the stuff naive learning and
social networks and the wisdom of crowds
which is actually the first paper i ever
published um
and we were interested if you know
francis golden's wisdom of crowds famous
you know thought experiment and then
real experiment um about aggregating
information from a lot of people that is
often used in teaching we took his
setting and brought it to a network so
the setup is that people have in
people's initial opinions are
independent private signals
of
a truth so think the theta is some
unknown variable we don't know much
about it let's say we have an
uninformative prior but we do get
signals and everybody's signal is an
independent signal of theta with a mean
zero error that's just a definition of
epsilon and the errors can have all
different you know variances so there's
going to be some interval of variances
of people's different signals
and the basic question is when is
consensus close to the truth when is the
after talking allah degroot when will
people believe something pretty accurate
well here's a little um
so let's think about that
let's remember first of all that
consensus is
eigenvector weighted initial opinions
and we see pretty quickly that we're
interested in a sort of
you know if we and i guess one thing we
should note immediately is that if the
population is small
if you have five people then no matter
how they're connected they're going to
be fundamental limitations to how well
they can learn about this data they just
don't have that much information but if
the population is kind of big then you
might hope that they might get enough
information and then the question is
will the network help them aggregate it
correctly so these people get the
information but they don't talk in a
centralized way they don't put all their
guesses in a common bin so that we can
do our little undergraduate class
exercise they just chat i'll degroot and
when will they aggregate well
well so let's bound we can write a
little simple bound on the error in
consensus
and i'm going to first be interested in
an l2
you know i'm going to bound the variance
or sorry the the
expected squared error
of their um
of their guess so consensus is c
and here i've just written variance of
consensus
in a funny way right well i know that
i know that what consensus is from the
right hand side
so by this standard variance formula i
can write it as a sum of the squares of
the weights
in the consensus
times the variance of the individual
people's deviations from the truth which
are epsilon
and i can bound that
now what am i using here so e bar is
defined to be the maximum
of anybody's eigenvector centrality so
if you have a star where there's one
person in the middle and everybody's
paying everybody has a link to that
person you can calculate that person's
centrality will be a half no matter how
big the star is and so
maximum centrality will be a half if you
have some kind of symmetric network like
a circle or a complete graph everybody's
centrality will be one over n by
symmetry right and so e bar is the
maximum centrality well we can bound
this if i just factor out an e out of
each one of these
then i can bound
this
like this and i'm going to lazily bound
the variance of the opinions
by the maximum variance
and then i observe that this guy the sum
of the e i's
by definition adds up to one
so that tells me this upper bound of e v
of e bar v bar so the maximum the bar on
this
variance of the consensus
is
the maximum variance times the maximum
centrality
and if i then
yeah if your epsilon eyes are not
independent are there also analysis for
that ah yes so you can do any bring
whatever
exactly bring whatever weak law
triangular array result you want and you
can apply it right
um
and so then applying chebyshev once we
see immediately that the probability
that the consensus deviates
by
um
that the consensus deviates from the
truth by some delta can be bounded by
stuff let's treat everything as
constants except the the maximum
centrality so i want what i really want
to think about is a sequence of networks
which is growing
and
you know larger and larger networks each
of them has a maximum centrality and you
can see that what you're going to need
for this number to grow small say you've
fixed delta to be a small number you
know 0.01 what you need is that
e bar the maximum centrality is going to
decay so let's kind of
make that statement if i fix everything
the bounds on variance i fix positive
numbers here and consider a sequence of
networks you can very immediately show
that so
in the asymptotic framework what's the
question it is does the consensus
converge in probability to the truth if
a sequence of networks has that property
we say it's a wise sequence of networks
right
and it turns out you can immediately see
from this calculation in a little
a little side exercise that's going to
happen if and only if the maximum
centrality decays to zero as your
network grows large
so yeah
i mean so of course chebyshev gives you
the upper bound and you see that if this
goes to zero that probably will go to
zero how do you get it to be an if and
only if statement so i
i said that the lower bound on variance
is going to be uh fair enough
yeah
so can you assume the centrality
in the sense that all
it's a definite i mean so the defining
property
pins down e up to scale
and we typically normalize it to one
which is a free normalization but it
does help normalization helps with these
calculations so it's the one we use
um other questions
so um
let me say something super quick i i
wanna actually there is a kind of graph
on question so so far you know i i
wouldn't blame you if you've been
sitting here thinking that um
this is all
mathematically quite straightforward so
far but it's kind of interesting
surprising how quickly you can reach a
question that i still don't know the
answer to so before i say that one i'll
quickly say you know
the eigenvector centrality vector is not
the most intuitive object for for
everyone and so a natural question
people ask is like well what does it
take to keep this away from zero and so
one simple answer is a prominent group
right so let me make a little definition
we're going to call a group alpha
prominent if everybody outside the group
pays at least alpha attention to it now
maybe directly maybe just they directly
put weight total alpha on people in that
group but it would be okay if they do it
indirectly too so in in two or three
steps of distribute updating or 10 or
whatever if they put
if they ultimately have arrows in the
matrix w to the power t
that add up to at least alpha into that
group we're going to call the group
prominent right and so it's very
immediate and this is a simple little
exercise again suitable for an
undergraduate course that if
m is alpha prominent then you can give a
lower bound on the maximum centrality in
the group it's going to be lower bounded
by you know something about alpha and
then divided by the cardinality of m so
if you have a sequence of networks and
in each of these networks you have a
prominent group of size let's say at
most 12
then no matter how big the networks get
they're not you're not going to get the
wisdom condition you can think of that
as something like the media or the
kardashians or whoever right who absorbs
a non-vanishing share of the influence
in the population no matter how big the
population gets
and so that's a that's a very
straightforward
anti-wisdom result it's an obstruction
so
prominence is an obstruction to wisdom
let me close by saying one
tiny thing so here's something i don't
know and i think so
i try to
intersperse open questions into this and
i i think i'm going to leave them mostly
to the end if i have time but i will
very quickly say one uh one quest one
one open question now let me just say it
now um
we actually still matt and i were very
curious in 2010 about the other thing
what does it take for wisdom to be
achieved and i still don't feel like i
know a great answer
so you know
this is a very simple markov chain
question take a sequence of markov
matrices
the nth one of size n
and the question is under what hands-on
conditions that you can tell me not
using the word eigenvector
will the maximum entry of the
eigenvector
decay to zero as you grow your
matrix right
so
if you have um
if you have my little toy
favorite example where
influence is ultimately degree this
thing that comes from an unweighted
degraph the answer
the answer is trivial you just need
the
you need nobody to have a degree that's
a positive share of total degree right
that's kind of as as explicit an answer
as you can hope for
but if we move away from
these nice w in markov chain language
you're now in the world of
non-reversible markov chains and i asked
so i i asked actually when we were doing
this i asked percy diaponis and i
convinced him you know that it was he i
at least got him intrigued but i haven't
i i don't know really what
what is an answer that i don't know even
though what a nice answer would look
like we have some results in the paper
with that but it seems like having some
good understanding of the limit of wn
could give you a condition right
especially here's to make this
no now it can be any markov chain
now here's here's a concrete question
that even this question i don't know the
answer to suppose you have a uh erdos
randy random graph with let's say
um you know you can make the degrees
where you want log of n or something or
you can make a dense and suppose we draw
weights then randomly so we make the er
graph and then the weights will be
random subject to the graph so you have
10 friends and you're going to allocate
your friends according to some allocate
your weights to your friends dirichlet
let's say right some distribution
it sure seems like there's no execute no
reason that influence should pile up
here or there but i think even this
question if you have this randomly drawn
weights on a big markov chain um you
know will will the maximum influence
decay i don't know i would be if some of
you know methods i would love to hear
them
isn't it related this expansion property
so for
expand the type of thing yes but i want
to say that most most expander most
expander
stuff that i know
works
in the markov chain world it tends to
work in the reversible case which you
know in in the case maybe you know
results that i don't i'm talking more
about uh irrelevant to the mark of
changes to graph it's a graph of d
so i can think of the weighted graphs
and then you can somehow define the
trigger constant type of expansion or
vert expansion or the ice parametric
type of saying
then it certainly has to do with of
course the second eigenvalue of the
whatever
then it seems like that it has to do
with influence or whatever all the
things that we're talking about there is
no connection but these signal bonds
require
you making your makers but you might you
usually have a versatile markov chain
yeah and a constant can be defined in
that on the random wall sense like
particular
pathogenic ratio but in a purely graph
for absolute sense but this graph is
directed yeah yeah i know your issue is
always the same directive
so i think there are there are already
challenging math problems and so i'll
leave it there let me just super quickly
summarize and move on to the next
chapter so in this world someone's
weighed in the consensus is determined
by the network independent of additional
opinions if you paid attention to the
formulas and equal to a celebrated
measure of network centrality it gives a
rationale for targeting influentials if
you want to move the opinions in the
group and this turns out to be in
contrast and amin mentioned this briefly
yesterday in discrete action models
where a celebrated paper is by uh
kempe tardis and kleinberg and then a
nice recent paper by amin and co-authors
saying that with viral type diffusion
the rationale for network-based
targeting can be weaker with these kinds
of continuous action models there's a
very strong rationale and it's the one
that's emerged as sort of the workhorse
model in economics and
as a sort of complement to this result
if we want to if we want a network to
aggregate information well we don't want
there to be influentials we want we want
a kind of spread kind of democratic
network condition which i i think we
still don't understand well but it
captures the intuition that if you don't
satisfy it um influential the
idiosyncratic error of these influential
people will be overweighted and mislead
the crowd you have another question yes
paper you mentioned is the potential
problem with even cycles do you have to
in order to analyze condition on the
subgraph conditioning type of uh
because this conflict or whatever i i
forgot the name of this fourth cycle of
length four
yeah so i think another in our world
cycles for any cycle i guess
yeah we don't have i mean a periodicity
is a very weak condition to satisfy once
you're out
once you don't have periodicity nothing
combinatorial matters
really on the periodicity exactly
yeah which is a very realistic condition
in real social networks i'm not going to
have time to do this i will put this
slide up here it's in the youtube video
but basically any question you could ask
as i mentioned you know do you want to
make your way stochastic do you want
your links maybe i stopped listening to
you if our opinions are too far apart um
these extensions have been studied i'll
flag this beautiful paper
which is a working paper by some
excellent mit students and uh syria
voglio which which is the cutting edge
model on this kind of topic and has a
great bibliography people have combined
diffusion type models and voter type
models with degroot you know there's
some technical connections even with
classic motor models which are surveyed
in this mosul tamu survey there's a nice
aer paper very recently by banerjee and
co-authors
about combining a viral model and then
degree so people become aware of an
issue virally you become aware that
there's such a thing as a micro finance
program and then you form opinions about
it degroot wise so people are combining
them and it leads to some very
interesting math with voronoi sets and
subtleties that don't emerge in the
standard degree model
and
there's a sort of textbook for this part
of the lecture which is a survey i have
with sadler
which overviews a lot about the degroot
model including questions of why would a
statistician
adopt a degree type updating rule and
actually in a recent paper with dasrata
and hak
we have a foundation where if the world
is changing if theta is not fixed but a
ar1 stochastic process a mean reverting
process then there's actually a
rationale even if you're fully bayesian
for updating your beliefs in a good way
updating your estimates in a different
way so it's a rich subject that still
has a lot of
a lot of i've given you a very
elementary kind of way into it but i
encourage you to check out any of these
if you want
a pretty immediate dive into some deep
questions that we still don't um have a
full handle on
i already told you about this so um i'm
gonna it's also obviously extremely
relevant for practice but
what matt pointed out yesterday and this
is a quote that i got from a paper by
bendel kleinberg and uh
iran
which is a sociologist's crack card
writing that in the real world consensus
is not reached and so we care about
the the structure of
he says that social scientists you know
sociologists and others are likely to be
more interested with explaining the lack
of consensus the variance in beliefs and
attitudes that we see in actual
influence context and so matt
began to talk about that yesterday and i
want to give you now with your increased
familiarity with the degree model i want
to tell you a bit more about that so
matt did a great job setting this up one
of the central features of social
networks is homophily love of the same
it's observed on every important
demographic and social dimension
we know from
yesterday's talk in this recent nature
paper this pair of nature papers that
it's
income homophily is very predictive of
um demographic of sorry of economic
mobility
um and we know that in schools for
example you know on dimensions we might
care about independently like race you
have way less interaction across groups
than under uniform mixing so this is
like a very robust deep feature of
networks and at the same time we know
that polarization and disagreement are
politically highly salient phenomena so
there are a lot of papers we
matt and i have a qje paper in 2012
which was very motivated by disagreement
and recently of course throughout covet
and the
2016 election in the u.s and so forth
there's been a lot of writing of which i
have some
sample citations here
describing the importance of
polarization
and documenting it in on political and
health and other issues
and so an extremely
relevant question is what role does the
network play in the structure and
intensity of polarization and also what
interventions might make a difference so
that's sort of the second
the second chapter of our little um
exploration today
so let me play this little video for you
again this network here i've set up the
opinions differently i've set up these
guys to have the
black initial opinion these guys to have
the white initial opinion and i'm now
having i'm now letting the process run
this is two steps four steps
ten steps you can see that even after
ten steps this
projector screen here kind of um
exaggerates it a bit these guys do have
some dark in their in their
opinion but you can still see a very
intense gradient after 10 steps of
updating that perfectly tracks the sort
of um
network structure in a way so that's
what the
and if you think about it we
when we were studying the consensus
stuff we were interested in this one
vector which is like who's going to
matter for determining this one real
number opinion but now there's a
different thing which is this whole
spectrum of disagreement right so this
is sort of if you'd like a second order
piece of the theory which is like what
happens
before consensus and this kind of stuff
happens so let me show you a little
movie this is a simpler network but what
i've done here is i've set up
i've set up um
people in a little
two diamond network here to have
different initial opinions i just
selected them you know somewhat at
random and then i let them update and
i'm playing the video for you in kind of
continuous time
you can see
that over time they are
so their opinions have updated quite a
bit and now you see that this this left
diamond
is sort of on the left of this issue and
let's call that the light and then the
right diamond is on the right and over
time it is the the disagreement is
decaying but it takes quite a while
for it to decay away
and
here what i've done is i've plotted
these opinions
over time
um
you know you see them converging to a
consensus which is between point two and
point three or two and three i've given
them you know
uh
so they're going here but you can see
these curves say how they're going there
and let me play so
let me just play this movie pausing it
so
at this point you know early on
they haven't there's no there's nothing
relating their opinions to their to
their group membership that much you
know the opinions are all over the place
but after we've let the process run for
just a little bit of time maybe over
here
you see that there begins to be a lining
up where you can already see kind of the
left people here are
um
you know
being
found over over here and the right
people are being found over there so i
think where i've stopped it is right
about where the first separation occurs
and then if we let them
update a little more
you know
maybe we stop it here by this point we
can see there is a very clear gradient
these guys are all dark these guys are
all light so they've separated
and then you kind of see that the groups
the rest of the convergence is at this
group level right the groups are sort of
the
this left group is moving slowly right
where the right group is moving slightly
leftward but they're doing this kind of
as a group
right
so c is what opinions converge to
and we've already studied that
matt mentioned yesterday that the
there's a if you want to know what the
rate of this is right you can see this
kind of an exponential decay if you want
to know the rate of that decay it turns
out to be the second eigenvector of the
updating matrix
and there's something else pretty cool
which is that we can tell how opinions
are ordered
so there is a the magic vector which
i'll tell you more about a vector called
q
which says in once all of this stuff has
settled down how are people ordered
along the axis of opinions
turns out there's an ordering which is
independent of the initial opinions
independent of a lot of details that
emerges in this world so let's talk more
about that let me state a math math
theorem for you
so this is
stated by the mars of iona since weeble
and further studied by matami
in this in this qj paper i mentioned so
if you want to know
the deviation of mr i from from
the eventual consensus opinion
well first of all the rate at which that
deviation is decaying is given by the
second i should actually have put
absolute value here let's assume the
second eigenvalue is positive to keep
things simple
the rate of decay is governed by the
second largest eigenvalue of the matrix
but what's interesting is that the the
sort of direction of the of deviation
where you are relative to others is
given by one number q and what's this
number
it's an eigenvector of the updating
matrix
but it's the one associated with the
second with the second eigenvalue so
when we were studying consensus we were
focused on the eigenspace corresponding
to the largest eigenvalue one of the
markov matrix now the second order the
second deviation will be governed by the
second eigenvalue and its associated
eigenvector so we here we've
diagonalized let's take our matrix to be
diagonalizable you have a
eigenvector on the right here q2
and so
summarize what's going on the speed of
convergence is governed by the second
eigenvalue and this ordering that we saw
emerge in the little picture is is
actually an eigenvector of the network
and kind of remarkably
no matter how i configure their initial
opinions that spectrum how they line up
is determined actually by the network
alone which is
a fact you should be surprised by and
i'm going to show you i'm going to maybe
make it vivid
why why it's not
why it actually
has some
content this fact um so let me play
another movie for you what i've done now
is i've set these people up to update
about two issues let's call them guns
and abortion right issues that you might
think people could have all sorts of
combinations of views on and each of
these issues will be separately
discussed in the network we've shown in
the little two diamonds network
according to a degree process and the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to show you their opinions
you know with these kind of tracer plots
here are their opinions evolving they're
converging to a consensus which you can
kind of see there that's the middle
point that they're all flying toward
um
they're getting there in some kind of
way so movies still playing right
they're getting there in some kind of
way but maybe at this point you kind of
want me to do something which i'll
hopefully do
you might want me to zoom in
because you know once they start getting
close it's kind of hard to see what's
going on so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create a camera which
flies inward zooms in
to keep the scale of the picture
equal to the scale of their disagreement
so let me show you that movie
maybe play them i don't know if i won't
play well yeah i can play them
simultaneously
so here you see the normalized picture
as they're flying together
the normalized picture
shows you the details of how they're
lining up on these two issues
so you see that
they're lining up along some kind of
axis right and what i want to flag is
that
on both issues so let's let's start with
this this y-axis issue let's say that's
abortion their political views are
lining up in this order like this purple
person
then two people on top of each other
then this green person and
so forth right
each person has it as we go down the
spectrum that's the exact same ordering
as we see on the other issue right
and that fact would emerge regardless of
exactly how i set up the initial
opinions generically the only thing that
the initial opinions would do is they
would
swing around the line itself the
ordering would be fixed but the
orientation of the line depends on the
initial opinions
so this is this this is the expression
of unit dimensionality that even though
in principle their opinions could occupy
this rich two-dimensional space or
n-dimensional space they'll actually end
up all lined up along a line right so
you should be that's not at all an
obvious
um so this is an explanation of um why
the political spectrum in the us is sort
of one-dimensional just kidding but uh
but uh
it helps us see the mathematical concept
yes go ahead
the two issues are like propagating the
same thing in the same number absolutely
yeah so same network but two different
issues
and so the last thing i want to mention
is what is you know you might be so
it is still true that there's a question
of how much polarization will there be
right it could be you kind of saw on one
of these issues there was actually much
less disagreement than on the other
issue
and so in math the scale of polarization
the size of it is determined by this by
the scaling thing a
and i can actually tell you what a is
this coefficient this a is equal to the
second to
a second eigenvector okay it's actually
the left-hand second eigenvector over
here
times the vector of initial opinions
okay so that thing is is also
related to eigen things but it's more
subtle you have to take
the way that you set up the disagreement
to begin with and and take the dot
product with some vectors so let's let's
get an intuition for that so it's a
left-hand second eigenvector of w it's
the one associated with m
to be contrasted with the right hand
second eigenvector of w which is the
thing that govern their ordering okay
so
to better understand that let me show
you two examples
if you set up x0 this the initial
disagreement to be
in this way which somehow tracks the
underlying group structure right then
the dot product of p2 with that x0 will
be big it has a big projection onto the
p2 is i'm just telling you
happens to look exactly like this so
when i set up this x to be like this it
loads heavily on to p2 and this is the
kind of disagreement that can be
sustained for a long time hopefully
you'll find that intuitive it's set up
to
resonate with the network's own
structure of sustaining this agreement
on the other hand if i set up the
initial opinion to be like this this
toggling thing that happens to be
basically orthogonal to p2 it's
orthogonal to the network structure and
so this will not sustain disagreement
because it doesn't really pick up on and
actually this came up in matt's
um
talk yesterday because he said when you
compute the spectral homophily the
lambda 2 of these social networks in
real life
you sometimes get a very high number but
it doesn't lead to high
income
segregation
and it doesn't lead to
the persistence of a mobility
and so the reason for that is it may be
that for some behaviors or beliefs the
disagreement is set up orthogonal to the
biggest split in the network and so it
won't get it won't sort of
manifest in this way so so i think you
learn hopefully this you know
it's kind of interesting to me in these
models how quickly you get into some
fairly subtle stuff and i want to make
yeah
so first of all what are the
conditions you need from a side too
um
so not much i
let's assume let's say positive so let's
say the second largest eigenvalue will
be
positive okay
um and i guess in general it might be
complex so
and this is actually has something to do
so
matt and i wrote our qj paper on hoffely
in the setting
of the
simple setting where you just take a
weighted graph
and you
do this you take an undirected graph you
normalize so you get this degree matrix
coming from
an undirected graph there it turns out
that even though the first eigenvector
theory is pretty boring this stuff is
already pretty rich right so that's the
that's sort of what markov chain people
call the reversible case so most of
what's known about these models is in
that case some of it like that lambda 2
controls the speed of convergence there
is a version of that for basically an
arbitrary you know a generic markup
matrix you have of course done but you
you set it aside so can you say that is
it an arbitrary path is that a craft
there's a
matrix w it's just a random workbench is
coming from the graph g
what are your conditions
so
let's say
yeah
it stated a little bit like physics but
take a take a row stochastic matrix w
so let me say let me say the
let me say one version
take an
undirected weighted graph a symmetric
matrix g construct the markov matrix as
i've described
um as long as your initial graph was
connected um
then
this theorem will hold exactly
exactly as i as stated um let's let's
also make the weights generic not four
cycles yeah but i'm also going to make
my initial g generic so i have to worry
about generic direction
just drawn from the let the weights be
be drawn from some measure absolutely
continuous with respect to the back so
i'm going to not worry about exactly
zero weights or anything
no no according to some joint
distribution just ruling out
to just rule out ties among eigenvalues
and other non-generic things that would
make me have to say
more um so yeah but then you can have
you know this is and this is a standard
markov chain mixing time type of
analysis in eigenvalue with eigenvalue
techniques yeah so just a clarifying
question on that so we are still in a
reversible markov chain
so
here's where we get more into physics
actually everything i've told you is
basically works even outside the
reversible case
but
and and for this part you can state a
rigorous result there's stuff i'm about
to tell you where we've heavily used
people have me and everybody else have
used reversibility a lot where
i don't think it's economically
important and so instead of open
questions is about how to relax so let
me actually tell you about that
can i ask something as well because in
your diagnosis
you seems to
have a condition that all the
eigenvalues are different
yes so i'm saying
that just uh
this is actually for some later um well
one thing that all different will give
you is automatically no jordan blocks
you know everything you just get
everything separate but there will be
other
other results for which i care about
even lower eigenvectors but for this one
you just need to separate the second and
was wondering third the times like here
we are seeing that it's a long long run
average and more and older
eventually
so i think there will be some time
uh the initial mothering that's not
politics
yeah
so actually let's go back i think i have
the picture um
well
it it's basically when the third item so
loosely when the third that's governed
by the ratio of the size of the third
eigenvalue to the second right that once
you when the
the other other stuff dies away
like the third relative to the second so
so there's that other there's another
gap there and if you have and so
actually if you have ties or near ties
and one eigenvalues this structure that
sticks around will be
um will stick in this other random stuff
will stick around longer and be richer
so but if you have a third eigenvalue
that's
are thinking fast
exactly
yes if we have time so my actual
question was so if if i can map
intuition from reversible markov chains
if this kind of
um you know obviously the first line of
factor is to do fish
so for the second eigenvectors you know
the left eigenvectors
usually are kind of you can interpret it
as kind of the most stable perturbation
of the steady state and then similarly
the right has a like the sort of most
stable perturbation of the state space
so is it right to just try to map that
intuition to the ukraine language that
you just described like that is why it
gives the ordering that's also why
yeah
i think that's a good intuition that
it's this perturbation that's capable of
sustaining itself the longest from the
steady state projection and so the left
one just kind of translates to
polarization yes
okay it's the same thing
so your d i vector just to get my my
markov chain correctly
your e is just the
stationary probability exactly
okay so
the eigenvector is for np of q2 is on
the same side as the stationary
distribution
yes the the cube that government no so
here's the one
here the right hand eigen vector the
first right hand eigen vector is all
ones
the second one is q2
on the left
the first one
is e
right and then this other one is p2
which is the one that uh
the one that we were
using to dot dot with x in order to
decide how big this disagreement was
going to be so in the reversible case
these two
are they're not exactly the same but
after but after a twist if you suitably
if you conjugate by a diagonal matrix
you actually p2 and q2 are basically the
same thing
but in general they're they they're not
in you know and for interesting non so
for outside my little favorite example
derived from an undirected graph these
two things could be
quite different and
in the diagonalizable case where sorry
in the yeah in the case where all
eigenvalues are real right so the case
where
um
basically your matrix is conjugate to a
normal matrix everything is easier but a
lot of what's interesting about this
model as you might and i hope you see
from this might emerge when there's some
differences between when p2 and q2 might
not track exactly the same thing right
there's some room for so that stuff my
my quick sort of summary is that nobody
has really zoomed in on that stuff and
we don't know a lot about it yet
it's worth exploring
i'll give you a super quick kind of
related to that so we've been talking
about graphons a lot before we can
really start touching on some graph on
stuff
um
you know we've learned that
the
that the
second eigenvalue governs the speed of
convergence it's associated eigenvectors
governing the medium's run structure of
disagreement
we usually can't measure the whole
network if i ask what is the social
network of updating in this room
even if you did a full network census
you wouldn't be measuring exactly what i
care about you're asking maybe who you
hang out with but you know what we
really care about within the model is
how much does my opinion influence your
opinion that's a very hard thing to
measure
at the
level
so
what we have a hope of actually getting
that we might believe is a structural
model of course with error in it of how
our attributes like our academic field
our gender our race whatever you want to
throw in there affect our links right
and so
the question is you know if you if all
you could actually get if if we can't
get
the full
precision of an exact knowledge of w but
we can approximate w is coming from a
statistical model of how people's you
know what christian talked about the
very first animal we've been talking
about multiple times if our
interactions are predicted by these
attributes in noisy way how well does
that commute with this model if you had
a model like that how well could you
sort of use the degree model without
knowing exactly everything
so that's kind of an important topic so
here's my little stochastic block model
picture right we have these groups and
they might have very complicated links
but if we sort of
somehow manage first of all to cluster
these people so we know who's who
and then we
look at the average linking
probabilities
across groups and then we forget exactly
the people and we just focus on this
group level thing you know to what
extent can thinking about this thing a
reduced system focusing only on the
group level stuff tell us information
that we really care about about the
original network right and so
if you think about this in adjacency
matrix terms there's some let's go back
to the graph world there's some zero one
adjacency matrix among these groups
which is very complicated very rich very
noisy
but if you kind of smooth it out and you
only you average across the blocks you
get some very low dimensional structure
right and the question is to what extent
can you analyze can you carry through
some of the analysis that i've told you
about to the low dimensional um you know
i guess this is a
in my
maybe i'll leave it here if you just
blur your if you make your eyes blur you
see the low dimensional version
um
and so
um
pure dense well actually we have results
matt and i have results for links for
as long as you're willing to have a
degree at least log in you can have the
results i'll tell you uh
you know
so one result we know is that you can
is that
if you take this so let me talk be a
little more precise you can construct
this representative agent system
where
instead of thinking of a link between
person i and person j you think of link
a link from group k to group l as the
typical weight placed by a group k agent
on all group l agents right so if
degrees are growing if my degree grows
you know like 100 you can get a pretty
good statistical prediction of what
fraction of my friends are going to be
let's say all the different races and
you can construct a fake degree matrix
on the races let's assume those are the
groups
and the hope is that this gives you a
good approximation of things we care
about but of course the stochastic block
model is a very crude approximation you
might say for income should be in there
right and if i now want a model of the
network
where i don't just think linking
probabilities in expectation are
determined by race but i also want some
continuous variables in there now i have
a graph on like object i have a sort of
smooth you know i have a rich set of
attributes which is somehow going to map
into link probabilities and then i'm
going to want to do
some version of the analysis i told you
about with knowledge of the full network
and i'm going to be curious about things
like can i
you know predict
so a simple question is can i predict
the eigenvalues can i predict the speed
of convergence knowing only the
large-scale structure and it turns out
there's a beautiful theorem
which is that if you can write your
adjacency matrix as probabilities of
links
plus
a matrix of deviations e and let's say
these deviations are independent
then you can show that in operator norm
or in spectral norm
your deviation matrix is going to have
um
you know under assumptions the typical
thing that people do is show that that's
o of root n
while the eigenvalues of your big
adjacency matrix
um are going to be
more like n
okay and so
uh or something
what really matters so actually here
i'll work in the dense case if you have
a dense network then the eigenvalues of
the main part the predictable part are
going to be scaling like n and the noise
is going to be scaling like root n so
you can kind of pick up on the main
structure in the adjacency matrix now
then you have to do a little work to
translate all this business into the
stochasticize into the debrude matrices
right so there's if you look up if you
open your favorite random matrix theory
book the first results you'll see are
more applicable to the you know for
example once you once you do my
normalization thing you've introduced
correlations now
whether you know how my how my links are
normalized depends on my other links and
so you have to deal with that but people
have so you can see our qga paper for
some methods on how to do that and in
general there's a beautiful theory
in that is surveyed in this nice
monograph called spectral methods and
data science for telling you how you can
who relationships between the eigen
things of the expected matrix the small
and orderly linking probability matrix
and your big and noisy realized link
matrix so it turns out there's a theorem
that helps you control eigenvalues which
you can use to control to show that you
can in fact predict the second
eigenvalue of the noisy matrix very well
knowing just the group structure
and you can even there's a corresponding
and
higher powered theorem called the
davis-con theorem which is about
being able to relate the eigen spaces
and so even those vectors like p2 and q2
are going to be predictable based on
large scale structure right so we don't
have you know given our time i would
love to dig into these into these um
subtleties and i'm not going to
dig into them in any richness but i do
want to say that there's a whole set of
fascinating questions that that use
these kinds of techniques to say how
much is predictable about the group
processes based on group level structure
and this theory
certainly in the group literature has
been developed exclusively in the
reversible case in the case where the
weight matrix is derived from some
symmetric matrix but in real life
asymmetry is an influence if you think
about me following you know taylor swift
or whoever those are asymmetric
influence relationships and so
asymmetries and influence are first
order for anything you would want to use
the group model for but mathematically
especially in this
disagreement theory we know almost
nothing about uh
what is what any of these results look
like with just with uh is without the
reversibility so i think that's an area
it might be a little too far beyond
current techniques but i have if you
want to talk to me i have a bunch of so
you imagine for example that
then having so if i want to generate
this ultimate matrix usually i need two
features right so then i have sort of a
feature for outlets and in links if you
have one for all different in-links and
then if you connect
you will use sort of one of the two
feature sets to connect in one direction
good exactly so that would be that's a
that's a nice model i hope it was
audible under the christian suggested a
model where you sort of have features
that predict links in one direction
features that predict links in the other
direction they don't need to line up and
you could try to sort of basically think
of your you know that would be
ultimately you project onto a network
that looks directed but it has some
structure as well
sorry just to understand i mean when you
move to the estimate like the
non-symmetric case is the issue that you
lose like i didn't vector
stability
is that one of the issues well there are
many issues so you're saying what's the
issue to pushing beyond yeah i mean i
guess like there's this usual examples
where like if you take like a
non-symmetric square reach if you add
some tiny noise in one corner
so i guess
it's just that people have used the
symmetry assumption to rule out that
problem and all others in reality the
things that go really wrong are much
more
are uh you know there are counter
examples like that and
basically much weaker conditions would
suffice to give you the convergence uh
but
i'm not sure if i'm answering your
questions
no i'm just trying to understand like
oh no this is why so this is actually
why i don't think that there are um this
is not like some areas where people are
these these open problems are i think
for the most part very low hanging fruit
because i don't think people have been
trying that hard there are these
heuristic things people believe because
the first people to do them in this case
us were too lazy to push beyond that
case and i think there are many
the economically important extensions i
don't think require fundamentally new
techniques they just require
doing it carefully and and so i'm
pointing out that in some of these
things the
not the the directed case hasn't been
understood well but could be with a
little work if you're curious about it
it's my
um is my is my feeling okay um
so
this is just a summary of the things i
said
for display on the youtube channel okay
so we have about 15 minutes and uh
i'm going to move so
i'll begin my next module let me just
quickly move the display
i want to talk a little bit about
that i want to talk about
about a different class of models which
is closely related but moves closer to a
to a different part of economics
which matt briefly mentioned
so we've been working with a mechanical
updating degree process but i kind of
told you that it was a benchmark useful
for thinking about richer economics
richer game theory and matt has already
brought up sort of game theory and how
network games
allow us to link network ideas to
fundamental economic concepts like
externalities and so forth
um and i'm going to tell you now at the
end of this lecture in the beginning of
the next one that understanding some of
so the degree model we could keep our
heads free of the subtleties of
economics optimization all of that it
was we just had a mechanical process i'm
going to tell you that with the
intuition you've developed by by
thinking about that you can understand a
lot about interesting network game
models
which have more optimization and
economics in them
and
a virtue of modeling agents who have
preferences is that we can
ask questions about welfare so that's
maybe a distinguishing
hallmark of the economic approach
networks that if you're just doing the
route model as a you know simple
mechanical model of how people behave
then whatever you want to assess about
it has to come out as extra
you know you just say i'm curious about
this measure of disagreement or
polarization or whatever if you have an
economic model underneath there's a
ready-made set of questions like are
these people behaving efficiently what
could we do to improve their welfare
that come from the preferences that give
rise to the behavior that's one of the
glories of economic models and so i want
to show you in a very simple setting how
we can kind of
bring in an economic model that inherits
much of what we've learned
from our degree studies so far
so we're going to study a game which is
a coordination game with continuous
actions
there's going to be a motive for people
to take actions close to personal ideal
points or favorite actions and you're
also going to be interested in your
actions being close to some others
so we have this um community
you could there are two examples i'll
talk about one is if you imagine a
pretty so here the actions can be in
some high dimensional space
rn which doesn't have to do with number
of people but maybe there's like six
choices we're making maybe technological
choices how much do i use tech do i use
linux or windows you know choices in
some technological space let's make it
continuous and when you choose this
bundle you like being closer to your
co-workers because it's easier to
coordinate but you also have your
favorite tools another model which maybe
i'll focus on more is opinions when you
choose a political position on an issue
like affirmative action or you know free
trade
you have your own views about what's
right but to the extent that you're not
really receiving much information a lot
of this is about social you know you
don't like constantly feeling like your
friends all think you're you're crazy
and so people again have a have a motive
to keep their opinions closer or their
expressed opinions at least closer to
what their friends say
and the basic questions are how are the
primitives the ideal points what people
fundamentally like to do or believe and
also their um the network they're
connected in how does that affect
welfare in equilibrium and if you had a
planner who could start to intervene and
do things like
you know show people ads again or or do
some other intervention that would
change their behavior what would be that
person's
strategy if they wanted to increase
welfare or decrease it if you're putin
and you're trying to create discord in
the united states prior to the election
what's your best bet to exploit the
network structure it's those kinds of
questions
um and so we're going to i'm going to
tell you but before getting to and
that's where we're going to go but i
want to tell you and maybe this is the
will be the last main thing for today
i want to tell you about a coordination
game and how it ultimately reduces to so
i'll tell you how we exactly model it
and i'll tell you how it comes down to
very similar math
so
we have individuals they're taking
actions and let's make everything real
valued now again so they're taking real
actions every individual has a favorite
action fi
any i and j interact
uh so any inj can interact and if they
play if they meet each other to work
together let's say they're going to get
the following payoff they're going to
get a certain disutility from
miscoordinating with the person they
meet and beta is how much they care
about the other person and then one
minus beta the remaining weight
is
the distance of their action from their
favorite action so the way and the way
this works is we pick our actions once
and for all then we meet whoever we're
gonna happen to you know interact with
that day and we get the payoffs based on
the actions we chose in the morning when
we interact in the afternoon and you
know so if beta is high i care a lot
about coordinating with whoever i'm
going to meet
and but i do have some weight on my
favorite action
and the network
is just governing so gig gij will be a
graph here which governs the probability
or the share of time if you want that i
and j interact so my expected payoff
will be a weighted average of my
interactions
with every person i might meet so i'm in
a work group and i might need you or you
or you or you with each of you i get
this kind of payoff and my real payoff
will be the average of all of those
weighted by how likely i am to meet you
cosmetic
why do you have these negative numbers
there
yeah so
in economics we often we always maximize
and the statistician let's call this a
loss function and same one
so i'm sorry about that
mathematical physicists have a partition
function sum of e to the plus beta
energy so you have these energies that
you want to
max maximum
sorry
so when you choose an action you're
pulled toward your favorite action but
you're also full turn your neighbor's
actions and you should be that should
remind you of the group
and one question we could ask is what's
a nash equilibrium given a vector a
favorite point so if i bring you a
vector of favorite points which is just
determined by people's childhoods and so
forth and then they play this game
what actions will they choose in the
morning
so we simultaneously choose actions in
the morning not seeing anything or
learning anything we just know the
network we choose our actions and then
we get these payoffs so let's analyze
that game and then welfare right now
that we have these payoffs we can define
welfare to be the sum of payoffs in
equilibrium so
then you could imagine later we'll do
this you bringing in a planner who has
some control on f who can mess with f a
little bit and that person might be
malevolent wanting to minimize our
utility as much as he can with his power
to mess with that for benevolent seeking
to help us all out
so let me give you a picture so i'm
going to draw a lot of pictures in this
part where i have here i have a circle
network so here the gijs are all
everybody spends half their time with
their right hand neighbor and half their
time with their left hand neighbor
and
let's say we have a vector of favorite
points where mr one and mr two are
taking actions minus one i'm going to
depict those kind of vectors visually by
coloring the nodes according to the sine
of of f
so we're going to have both positive and
negative numbers here and then later the
size of these various nodes will
correspond to the size of the entry of a
vector so any vector you're thinking of
on the network i can depict by
coloring and sizing the nodes okay it's
just a visual convention
and so here we have a vector of favorite
actions where these
northeasterners happen to like the the
you know minus one action and these
these people happen to like the
uh plus one action and then you can ask
what that will translate to an
equilibrium so i pick some beta a half
maybe and i let these people play the
game and you can see that they're going
to conform their actions to
uh
other people's preferences because if
you're here like you know basically you
know that these people so these people
are deep in the south southwest
and they are surrounded by everyone who
shares their favorite actions so in
equilibrium they don't have to adjust
much they end up playing close to their
favorite action and their neighbors like
to play their favorite action whereas if
you're more on the edge it turns out
that you're somehow influenced by the
fact that you're on the border one of
your neighbors likes the other action so
they're pulled toward it so they're your
poultry so you can solve for the
equilibrium and you get some kind of
shape like this right
and so
um
now you can ask simple questions like
you know take this network versus this
network um how much disagreement will
there be like if you you can ask a
question like how much polarization
ultimately will there be in behavior you
know neither of these for a fixed beta
so unlike the degree model for a fixed
beta these people are not going to
have consensus they're going to have
reason to maintain their differences but
you can ask in this network how much
difference will they maintain
versus in this network right you might
have an intuition based on homophobia
that actually you know in this network
they're going to be much better at
sustaining the disagreement they have
whereas in this network it'll get
attenuated away but now with this
welfare function in the picture there's
another question which is which network
would you rather live in right and it's
going to turn out that under the
canonical welfare function you actually
strongly prefer to live in this
polarized looking network because the
people surrounding you agree with you so
even though there will be big global
polarization it'll it won't have much of
an effect on people's local worlds and
and the utilities so a utilitarian
welfare utilitarian actually likes uh
this world a lot more so there's and so
will you know
with each other
very good so let's actually do that
right now i'm not going to do targeting
but so i'm going to quickly do
equilibrium and then i'll do your
dynamics and that will stop there so i
started at 305 and i landed 335 and um
so here's the payoff and what i've done
now so this is the payoff you know
i've now averaged over your over your
friends and i'm i've brought back a
matrix w because i'm going to study it
well it's w is a arbitrary
uh matrix which
and for a little while i'm not even
going to require
row stochastic just put any matrix w
here so this is the expected expected
payoffs in the game we've been studying
looks like this
equilibrium behavior well you can so one
thing you can do and this is the whole
idea of nash equilibrium you take other
people's actions as given you take them
as numbers that you can't affect
and you think how would for any actions
that they might take how would i best
respond what would be my ai so that's a
very simple optimization problem right
taking all these numbers aj
of other people as as fixed numbers what
is your best response action what action
do you maximize is your utility so you
take a derivative
you you solve this problem and you get
that the best response action that you
have is a weighted average of
well
it's so actually let's agree let's take
w to be a real stochastic matrix this is
saying that it's an average of your
neighbors actions right w i j times the
action they're taking plus the remaining
weight
on your so this is an average of your
neighbor's action you put weight beta on
that and put weight one minus beta on
your favorite point that's your best
response
[Music]
so that too there will there will be a
two but it appears in both places and
then it cancels out
yeah
so you take the derivative and then
you know i get if i write that system
that i wrote up there if i if i take
that equation and i write it in vector
terms i get
this kind of equation
and if i solve it if i bring all the a
stuff over to one side and i and then i
invert
i get
a characterization of equilibrium
actions that depends exclusively on
known stuff the network and the favorite
actions
and i can use a formula that you all
know for writing out that inverse i can
write it as a as the sum of beta beta to
the power t times w to the power t right
and
you can see you can immediately see
that the same objects that determine
degroot opinions at various steps of
updating show up in this
game but now the way that you get your
consensus action it's almost as if you
took a degree process you let it run and
then you picked a random time to stop it
geometrically
that's actually mathematically what the
right hand side is so in some sense the
network game
captures actions which are very closely
related to the groot opinions but now in
this nash equilibrium reasoning
the second equality world either
whatever you want should be invertible
matrix or
this data
should be small yeah w is one stochastic
beta is a number less than one right
okay so that's why the matrix is
incredible and moreover all the entries
of all the entries of this inverse are
non-negative numbers that comes from
that
that's another clarifying question so of
course this depends on the geometry of
your network structure your neighbors
like you illustrated um but
so in that example you gave us f was
super simple it was plus or minus one
right so usually
it looks like this objective would not
only depend on the network structure of
your neighbors but maybe like the
geometry of the action space right
because if you had many neighbors and
then
the distance is only measured from you
to your favorite action like if their
favorite action is sort of closer to
yours that could also affect things
right so
so somehow that seems right but i'll
tell you that if i set up exactly this
utility function in an arbitrary
euclidean space just replacing this with
norm squared every formula i'm writing
would remain true so of course the
geometry would matter in so far as the
determined distances
yes it goes through so so this is
actually a better theory you know if
you're working in any space where you
have you know norms that look like a two
norm
be as rich as you want you can run this
theory and degrude actually observed
that when he was doing his thing he said
you can update over distributions or
whatever you want and the math all makes
sense right so that's a free
generalization
that we have so you have this matrix r
which i call r because in econometrics
this is called the reduced form effects
if you look at w they're like
the structural effects the ones that
govern the sort of direct
person-to-person influence but once you
roll together all the implications of
them you get this matrix which captures
the full equilibrium impact right so
naively the the first order structural
impact of my action on you is like my
favorite point increases so my action
increases so maybe that has a direct
effect on nicole because we're friends
but once you've rolled that through the
whole network indirect updating system
it's going to have an effect on you know
keymon over there because it and so
the the
r captures all those indirect effects
adds them all up in a way that of course
depends on the coordination weights and
so forth
and so last and and maybe this is a good
place to stop we see a powerful analogy
here between the root model and our
model because actually you know
i forgot to write an important
stipulation here
if you take beta up to one so you take
the coordination motive to be very
strong that should be a stipulation here
and i'll correct it when we resume next
time when the coordination motive is
very strong then this sum will put most
of its weight on very high
powers and so the powers that will
matter will be w to like a thousand and
so
what we'll converge to will be a
weighted average of our favorite points
weighted by what it turns out exactly
our eigenvector centralities so the beta
to one limit the high coordination
concern limit of this model recovers the
degree consensus right but before you
get to the but if beta is far away from
one you have some disagreement left
which is picking up that second and
third and so forth eigenvalues and is
giving us a much richer structure of
disagreement which you can then ask
about how can i you know how would a
planner want to manipulate that and is
the amount of disagreement in
equilibrium efficient and so those
quests so next time when we wrap up
we're going to do a very quick
completion of network game theory which
i'm going to do i'm going to sort of
pick some highlights but i think it's
important that we
do see there's beautiful work by by for
example uh bendel kleinberg and
iran which i want to mention and then
the main topic of next time will be
uh someone sent me this amazing picture
i don't know if you can see it says
eigen payments this is apparently a real
a real company but um people use these
models for thinking about macroeconomic
systems and bank systems and all sorts
of interesting um really what what you
know
your late layperson friends might think
of as economics um and it turns out we
can use a lot of the same insights to
think about really first order questions
around macroeconomic volatility and bank
regulation and so i'll at least give you
a taste of that in
the fourth and final networks
lecture so that'll be next time thank
you so much for your attention
hi everybody just before you go i just
wanted to remind you that
we have a town hall for the
uh
program participants about like
structuring reading groups and
everything for the rest of the semester
so we'll hold it in this room christian
yes at
four yeah